vous avez des gens qui avancent leur
pion et vous essayez de d'entourer le
epion ou le groupe de pions pour les
éliminer donc ça moi je suis très
intéressé par cette histoire détoxine
depuis le début le vrai problème la
vraie poursuite qui devrait faire c'est
contre le landset et contre cet essai
complètement délirant qui a pas eu lieu
qui est une plus escroquerie soi-disant
sur 80 000 personnes dont 10% c'est mort
avec un traitement qui a été prescrit
plusieurs milliards de fois c'est
délirant et à partir de ça l'OMS c'est
Monsieur Véran prennent une réaction
instantanée sur lequel il pourra pas
revenir et donc ça c'est la première
chose on dit d'abord c'est un truc qui
tue après on dit ça marche pas très bien
mais il y a eu j'ai eu l'occasion de
vous le dire il y a eu maintenant 393
études dans le monde sur
l'hydroxyroquine qui trouve globalement
à condition qu'on ne trie pas celle que
l'on veut qui qui trouve globalement les
mêmes résultats que nous c'est à dire
70% de
d'amélioration du pronostic c'est à dire
de mort en moins si on peut être
précocément et 42% si on traite chez les
patients hospitalisées c'est des données
qui sont très importantes et puis vous
pouvez toujours faire ce que vous voulez
les données restent là donc on a dit ça
pourquoi ils ont fait cette tribune
alors là mais parce que le dernier point
une fois qu'on a dit ça que vous avez
bien vu les gens on dit tout ça on passe
à la trappe le ministre
j'ai fini mon travail sur le covid sur
le traitement du covid pendant deux ans
je me suis consacré et on a traité 30000
personnes pas fait d'essayer
thérapeutiques mais il y en a qui ont
été traités avec de l'hydroxyrockéine
notre être inoxynastie tropicine
d'autres qui ont eu que de la
vitromycine d'autres qui ont du divers
nectar donc toute cette expérience qui
est unique au monde il est pour moi
nécessaire de la donner à analyser au
monde entier donc l'essentiel de ce
travail d'ailleurs je suis frappé que
personne n'en ai parlé c'est que nous
construit une banque de données et que
cette banque de données elle est dans
une banque de données américaine une
banque de données chinoises où il y a
toutes les données certifiées par des
huissiers pour pas qu'on nous accuse une
fois encore de mentir et cette fois-là
tout le monde peut l'utiliser c'est dans
l'histoire de la médecine alors c'est
dans l'histoire des sciences la plus
grande
expérience au monde dans un institut
unique sur le traitement et la prise en
charge du covid professionnel
vous avez bien vous avez fait des
traitements avec l'hydroxychloroquine à
Marseille pendant la pandémie donc là
vous nous le redites parce que c'est ça
qu'on vous reprend aussi voilà vous en
aviez le droit
mais bien sûr mais je veux dire je vais
vous donner trois exemples que j'ai bien
sûr je suis comme je suis un homme
combatif je suis un homme prudent
un en décembre 2021 effectivement je
suis passé devant le Conseil de l'Ordre
pour parce que certains personnes
avaient considéré que je n'avais pas le
droit parce qu'il y a d'identité et le
Conseil de l'Ordre a conclu que j'ai
parfaitement le droit j'avais pas mis la
vie des gens en danger et je peux vous
dire les résultats dans cette étude des
gens qui ont pris de l'hydroxyde le taux
de mortalité hospitalière des gens qui
ont pris des broxyclaoutim c'est de 7%.
c'est la plus basse série de mortalité
au monde d'accord donc bien entendu
j'avais le droit deuxièmement on a eu on
nous a envoyé les deux ministres nous a
envoyé
8 l'inspecteurs pendant 7 mois qui ont
fouillé tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé et ils
n'ont jamais reproché le fait que nous
n'ayons pas le droit
ils ont fait un magnifique rapport de
100 pages et ensuite un de mes amis a
demandé aux professeurs Salomon qui
était encore directeur général de la
santé avant qu'il parte à l'OMS tu es
d'accord que j'ai toujours le droit de
passer des
Salomon lui a dit bien sûr tu peux
prescrire si tu le considères que c'est
le meilleur traitement c'est ton noir
c'est le droit de prescrire c'est quoi
le problème alors professeur pourquoi
ils ont fait cette tribune là il dénonce
ils sont affolés ils vous rendez compte
du nombre de gens qui ont dit qu'il
fallait pas faire ça
l'inaction des autorités c'est à dire
ils ont fait une tribune pour que vous
en preniez plein la gueule non mais les
autorités elles n'ont pas arrêté d'agir
mais ils ont pas le droit d'empêcher un
médecin de prescrire un médicament qui
est un médicament ordinaire
écoutez je sais pas peut-être ça calme
un peu leur nerf moi je serai malheureux
et mal à l'aise si vraiment les gens
disent écoutez nous on pense que avec
notre traitement ici à Marseille on a
empêché 800 personnes de mourir à
l'échelle de Marseille si vous
multipliez ça à l'échelle de la France
les gens qui ont pris la responsabilité
de poursuivre de terrifier moi je suis
pas on peut pas me faire peur mais il y
a une quantité de médecins qui ont été
terrifiées il y a des gens qui ont été
suspendus par le Conseil de l'Europe
parce qu'ils avaient pas les capacités à
se défendre que j'ai de me défendre oui
et donc on a régné par la terreur pour
empêcher d'utiliser un des médicaments
les plus anodins du monde et les plus
prescrits dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et si maintenant on revient dessus c'est
les terrifie on voit bien qui vous est
rien arrivé quand on faisait pas tombé
dessus vous avez pas de prix de sanction
hein non
rien donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont alors
parce qu'ils veulent vous tuer
professionnellement j'ai l'impression
je cherche vous savez je cherche pas à
savoir ce qu'ils veulent je m'en fiche
un peu
quand vous avez lu La Tribune vous étiez
pas un peu énervé
non
[Rires]
moi je n'écoute pas les gens qui disent
du mal de moi je ne les lis pas et il
m'intéresse pas je fais pareil
j'ai remarqué j'ai remarqué que vous
étiez la cible aussi de de pas mal de
malfaisants bon on adore ça on vit très
bien avec ça non mais c'est vrai on vit
très bien comme ça on partira en
vacances ensemble professeur
on va être bien tous les deux non mais
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable je vous
jure on en rigole mais moi moi
professeur je suis content que vous ne
preniez comme ça mais moi écrire une
tribune je suis désolé les gars une
tribune pour dire que les dénoncer
l'inaction des autorités je suis désolé
mais qu'on est où là les mecs c'est quoi
Gilles Verdez surtout aujourd'hui oui
moi j'avais une question pour le
professeur parce que vous vous faites
une étude que vous appelez étude
d'observation observationnelle vous
dites elle sert et elle servira pour
l'histoire effectivement les Etats-Unis
et la Chine s'en inspirent et on a ces
sociétés savantes qui publient la
tribune donc professeur il faut être
clair c'est de la jalousie de la
mesquinerie du milieu médical à votre
rencontre ils veulent vous détruire
aujourd'hui
c'est un essai thérapeutique c'est un
essai vaccinal c'est-à-dire que ici
qualifié comme un essai vaccinal
d'ailleurs tous les gens qui ont été
vaccinés on leur a demandé leur
consentement pour pouvoir être vacciné
parce que le vaccin n'a pas été évalué
entièrement on peut pas évaluer un
vaccin en trois ou six mois parce que
vous le voyez bien d'ailleurs et donc on
demandait aux gens un consentement qui
est un mensonge puisque énormément de
gens qui se faisaient vacciner se
faisait vacciner parce qu'ils étaient
obligés de se vacciner pour avoir une
vie normale ou pour se déplacer pour
travailler à l'hôpital donc ça c'est un
véritable et ses thérapeutique illégal
qui ne répond à aucune des normes de la
Déclaration d'Helsinki par exemple qui
dit que les gens doivent pouvoir avoir
un consentement éclairé sans être
pénalisé s'ils ne consentent pas or
c'est l'inverse que l'on a fait ça c'est
un problème moral et si vous me demandez
ce qui est le fond du problème je pense
que ces gens ont peur parce qu'ils ont
fait des choses qui ne sont pas licites
ni morales et que finalement le temps
les retrouve alors
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a de la
jalousie
on avait parlé la dernière fois parce
que dans votre livre vous disiez vous
avez dit vous avez tapé sur des
collègues pendant que beaucoup de
collègues faisaient de la politique sur
les plateaux de télévision à Paris nous
avons continué à faire de la science à
Marseille votre livre il a dû les
énerver aussi
j'adore ça je sais pas je sais pas s'il
l'achète et bravo bah non ils ont dû
lire les petites phrases mais c'est bien
c'est bien ça vous fait ça vous fait
marrer j'aime bien moi ça écoutez
franchement moi je me sentais tenu de
rendre compte si vous voulez du travail
que nous avons fait avec toute mon
équipe je vous ai dit il y a des
centaines de bénévoles qui sont venus
nous aider pour téléphoner aux gens pour
saisir les données c'est la masse de
données qu'il y a là-dedans est inouï et
c'est la première fois et c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
c'est la première fois que l'on donne
les banques de données avant même de
publier l'article toutes nos données
sont disponibles pour tous les gens qui
veulent les voir et je peux vous dire
que c'est déjà consulté c'est déjà
analysé il y a des gens qui s'en servent
qui vont se retourner vers les donneurs
d'ordre pour leur dire mais pourquoi
est-ce que nous n'avons pas pu utiliser
ça
et donc c'est le rôle que j'estime que
je dois jouer c'est de donner tout ce
que j'ai pu apprendre et tout ce que
nous avons pu collecter pour que
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
en France est bien ailleurs plus
l'utiliser et en tirer une leçon alors
professeur je voudrais revenir sur deux
petites choses la semaine dernière on en
a beaucoup parlé sur on a beaucoup parlé
vous sur les médias dans les médias sur
les réseaux à cause d'une petite phrase
que vous avez dites vous disiez que les
vaccinés étaient moins morts que les non
vaccinés savaient surpris certaines
personnes selon qui vous aviez changé de
discours est-ce que on peut revenir
là-dessus
oui vous savez depuis le début j'ai
essayé d'expliquer une chose
les maladies il y a des maladies qui
sont immunisantes que vous connaissez
bien c'est les maladies de l'enfant
c'est des maladies qu'on fait qu'une
seule fois
[Musique]
la varicelle les oreillons voilà ça pour
ça on peut faire des vaccins
les remplacer et ces vaccins marchent en
général on a de très bons de très bons à
ça et puis il y a des maladies qui ne
sont pas immunisantes ou au moins pas
longtemps comme la grippe par exemple
vous voyez et comme le covid donc le
covid vous savez bien que il y a des
gens qui ont fait deux trois quatre
covid donc cette maladie n'est pas
immunisante donc l'idée qu'on va faire
un vaccin qui va faire mieux qu'une
infection naturelle qui n'est pas
immunisante n'est pas raisonnable
donc vous ne n’allez pas pouvoir avoir
un vaccin qui soit l'équivalent de ces
vaccins qui m'a ce que vous pouvez avoir
au mieux c'est un vaccin qui soit comme
le vaccin contre la grippe donc vous
avez pas changé d'avis
toujours pas changé d'avis mais dans le
vaccin contre la grippe ça ne va pas
vous empêcher d'avoir la grippe l'année
prochaine et parfois même pas l'année
même ça ça couvre je sais pas 70% du
risque mais chez les gens qui risquent
de faire des formes graves et bien ça
diminue le risque d'en faire et le ça
diminue le risque d'en mourir et donc on
sait très bien que les gens qui font un
covid ce qui meurent en plus de 60 ans
donc ça dès qu'on a vu qu'en été ça
n'empêchait pas du tout la contagion qui
n'avait jamais été testé par Pfizer et
Pfizer l'a dit ça veut dire que ça
n'avait pas de sens de faire une
vaccination généralisée et nous on l'a
su au bout de 6 mois parce qu'on voyait
que on posait la question aux gens il y
avait 2000 3000 personnes qui venaient
faire tester par jour on leur demandait
êtes-vous vacciner mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas vacciné et on regardait le
pourcentage des gens qui étaient POS
fait ce qu'il n'était pas très
rapidement on a vu que les gens qui
étaient vaccinés étaient aussi positifs
que ceux qui étaient pas vacciné et j'ai
une question c'est vrai c'est vrai que
les gens qui ont plus de 70 ans qui sont
ceux qui meurent ont un effet de la
vaccination dans les trois ou six mois
avant j'ai une question
de maïe Christophe qui me dit il est où
le covid il est où
il y en a toujours mais là là c'est
intéressant comme on est on est passé
dans une autre partie c'est une autre
forme complète le Sadio micron ça donne
pas les mêmes symptômes vous rappelez
les autres ça donnait plus on goûte et
plus là ça ça n'existe plus dans
celui-là mais en revanche il y a des
conjonctivites qu'on voyait pas dans le
premier il y a beaucoup moins
d'atteindre pulmonaires et du coup la
mortalité a été divisée par trois ils
ont pris dans la même population donc
c'est beaucoup moins grave c'est pas les
mêmes symptômes et malheureusement ce
virus là ne rentre pas par la même porte
que les autres virus avant et il n'est
pas sensible lui à l'hydro rocycload
d'accord ce matin vous étiez chez BFM
chez Bruce Toussaint vous avez menacé de
quitter l'interview
vous en foutez
qui est chef de service de pharmacologie
médicale au circuit de Bordeaux qui est
écouté ce type d'insulter
je l'écoute non je ne l'écoute pas je
l'accroche vous faites ça c'est pas
compliqué je ne parle pas aux gens qui
m'insulte je n'écoute pas les gens
insultes je ne sais pas c'est pas
compliqué il va pas
non mais non mais très bien on arrête
l'interview maintenant c'est bon c'est
bon professeur c'est bon ne vous énervez
pas mais pas besoin de vous énerver
comme ça il me le faire au coup de force
vous savez vous avez vous avez bien
remarqué c'est pas ma nature j'ai pas
l'habitude de me laisser faire
professeur je pense qu'on s'est mal
compris je ne vous proposais pas de
discuter avec le professeur molimar je
voulais juste je ne veux ni écouter je
ne lis pas vos bêtises je n'écoute pas
votre télé je ne lis pas les journaux
qui médisent de moi je le fais pas voilà
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
avancer
pour vous le professeur molimar est là
professeur je vous dis à liker je
comprends tout à fait les mecs ils
l'insulte toute la journée et sur les
réseaux il insulte tout et après ils
veulent il va lui poser des questions
non mais les mecs c'est des fous non
mais je te jure on est on marche sur la
tête non mais ça incroyable professeur
est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ouais ça vous énervé je comprends
moi je me serais barré non non mais
c'est pas ça si vous voulez les
apports humains et dans votre dans votre
monde c'est souvent le cas les gens
s'imaginent pouvoir jouer c'est ça le
rapport de force vous savez jouer des
rapports de force avec moi il faut
réfléchir avant
c'est pas ma nature de me laisser faire
vous avez bien fait professeur mon
professeur c'est que je vous vois comme
ça j'ai une idée d'émission
allô Didier les gens appellent et ils
posent des questions sur je vous jure
c'est vrai ça serait incroyable moi il
est hypnotique je peux rester des heures
à le regarder non mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai je le pense vraiment merci
Didier je vous jure moi je peux vous
entendre des heures pour vous écouter
parler pendant des heures et vous êtes
vous êtes chez vous là
vous avez fait Hanouka
[Rires]
c'est le c'est le cabinet de ma femme ah
d'accord va vous l'embrasser vous
l'embrassez de ma part je vous embrasse
la famille merci Didier et c'est bien
qu'on est qu'on est posé des choses ce
soir merci beaucoup de dire à vous merci
beaucoup